فعليا هناك خطر
لاطلاق شراره حرب اهليه في روسيا يمكن ان
يؤدي الى دمار روسيا كدوله موحده هذا امر
مهم جدا لذلك استطاعت استطاعت الصفقات
التي حصلت تدخلات من قبل الرؤساء الرئيس
لوكاشنكا وبعض الاشخاص المقربين للرئيسين
الى انهاء عمليه ما يسمى اطلاق حرب اهليه
في روسيا لانه لو بدا القتال يعني كل الان
يسال لماذا الروبوت السمح لقوات فاقدر
بالدخول الى روسيا اذا قرر ان عسكريا
كان القتال سيؤدي الى خسائر مثاليه استاذ
محمد الافندي هذا السؤال يعني بعد هذا
الاتفاق الذي ابرم بين الكرملين وقائد
فاجنر بواسطه بيلاروسيا رغم ان نتساءل عن
لماذا قبل بوتين
بهذا الاتفاق هل حقنا للدماء كما قال قائد
فاجنر
ليس عقدا للدماء وعندي عدم وحقنا للدماء
لعدم وجود شراره حرب اهليه يعني كما قلت
لك لقاء هناك في قطر حقيقي لبدايه حرب
اهليه وهذا ما يريده من دعم من خارج من
خارج روسيا هذا امر واضح جدا لانه لا يدور
قلب السلطه بروسيا افضل دائما روسيا سيده
الكريمه كل الحروب اللي خاضتها في التاريخ
لم تخسر ولا حرب الحروب التي تخسرها دائما
هي حروبها من الداخل وهذا احد الامس كان
هناك شراره لبدايه لذلك كان التفاوض من
نوع من انواع ما يسمى التنازل حتى لا
تشتعل حرب اهليه في روسيا يمكن يمكن ان
تشتعل لا نقول لك هناك شرارات ونعلم جيدا
يمكن ان تدلع النيران ولا احد يستطيع ان
ايقافها لذلك كان هناك تباسلات والطرفين
يعني بريكوجن بعد ما تورط تنازل عن كل شيء
اسمه فانذر واي قوات وتم نفيه يعني حاليا
هو خسر املاكه خسر كل شيء هو موجود في
بيلاروسيا كوضع منفي بالنسبه بعد النقاط
السياسيه قاتلها الرئيس بوتين يعني انا
اقول كمان انتصر يعني خسر من بعض من
شعبيات ايه عصر ان لم يعتقل
هذا نوع من انواع التنازلات لاجل البلد
يعني نقول ان رئيس بوتين خسر نوعا
ماريوجين خسر كل شيء ولكن انتصرت البلد
بعدم نشوب حرب اهليه روسيا دوله كبيره جدا
لديها قوم
رئيس بوتين مع الوضع هل مزيد من الضمان
للراي العام الروسي خرج بوتين اليوم
بالقول لانه واثق بالنجاح خطط بلاده في
اوكرانيا لان الاهميه هي اوكرانيا وليست
داخل الروسي
ما معنى الخيانه يعني لما يعني تصريحات
بالوجه الاخيره كان موجهه ليست ضد وزاره
الدفاع ولكن
وضد سياسه روسيا يعني حتى وصف البارحه
للخيانه استاذ محمود الافندي ونعلم ان
الرئيس بوتين كان قد قال في احد لقاءاته
السابقه انه لا يغفر الخيانه والان نتحدث
عن الاتفاق الذي جرى التوصل اليه برعايه
بيلاروسيا ما وضع ما سيكون وضع
بريكوجين في بيلاروسيا ونعلم هذا التقارب
تقارب الجيد بين مينسك وموسكو
كذلك
لا يغفر الخيانه اذا لم خيانه هي خيانه
شخصيه وخيانه الوطن بشكل عام وقياده روسيا
كامبراطوريه وكدوله عظمى لذلك
رئيس بوتن تنازلا او عمان عن ذلك ولكن بعد
التفاوض ان بعض المعلومات وصلت لانه كان
هناك يريد الخروج اما للسعوديه او
الامارات العربيه المتحده او احد اركان
تركيا والرئيس اردوغان حاول ايضا
للاستقبال في تركيا ولكن رف
ض الرئيس فقط ببيلاروسيا زارت تحت الاعين
الروسيه لانه روسيا دوله موحده
بالعسل بما يسمى هناك اتحاد
وبالاضافه الى اجهزه المخابرات واجهزه
الامن لذلك هو صحيح من ولكن تحت
يعني يمكن عندما يهدا الوضع ويسيطر الرئيس
بوتين على كل منافذ وعلى كل قوات ما اقدر
وينتج لها قائد جديد يمكن ان يقول يمكن ان
يعتقل او يقضى عليه باي شكل من الاشكال
هذا واعطاه فقط ضمانات للخروج وليس لحياه
لم ينتهي المشكل بالنسبه لروسيا لان
المجموعه مجموعه
فاغنر كانت تكن الولاءه التام لقائدها لكن
ربما بارساله الى بيلاروسيا كما قال يعني
الخبير العسكري احمد رحال من اسطنبول وهو
الان قد يكون مقايض الاقامه الجبريه سيكون
ربما من الصعب التعامل مع هذه المجموعه
التي تضم 25 الف عنصر
انا بنصحكم نصيحه واحده فقط لا تستضيفهم
القاتل روسيا في سوريا يعني هو دائما
فكيف يتكلم ذلك قوات فاقدر
العسكري ولكن الولاء العسكري عندما تشعر
ان قائدها خان
العسكري لم يخوض هذا امر مهم جدا لذلك
روسيا ستسامح فقط
القوات او
ستدمج قواتها تحافظ على قوات فقط التي لم
تدخل التمرد العسكري بينما القوات الاخرى
التي دخلت تمرض عسكري ستسرح وتعاد الى
مكان اقامتها يعني
فيني وبين الشعب
وعشره بالمئه سجناء العشره
من اشترك في التمرد لم يدخل العمليات
العسكريه مره اخرى ولا يسجل معه عقل هذا
امر مهم جدا لذلك الامور تحت السيطره
بينما هناك اخطاء روسيه طبعا هناك افكار
روسيه
هناك انه يمكن ازاله وزاره وزير الدفاع
لانه فعليا هو احد اخطاء التي حصلت تمرد
يعني هو ايضا مسؤول عن وزير الدفاع عن
الجيش الروسي وه
البارحه ومن حوالي ثلاث ايام لما دخل
بريجوجل الى روسيا يعني هناك احتمالات
ايضا لاقاله الوزير شيخون وحتى هناك نوعا
ما مرشحين الان من محافظه تونس يوجد الان
يقولون انه دفاع يعني العقاب ليس سيكون
ريجوجل